exactamente mucho más allá del apoyo
militar hay apoyo humanitario y hay
apoyo también burocrático Es decir para
que el gobierno devoró misceles que siga
operando hay tanques de pensamiento que
están estimando que la cifra total en
cuanto ayuda humanitaria burócrata y
militar asciende a los 75 mil millones
de dólares hoy solamente el departamento
de defensa anunció otros dos mil
millones de dólares más pero
concretamente en defensa de estos 75 mil
millones de dólares que Estados Unidos
le ha dado a Ucrania 46.000 han ido a
defensa es decir mucho más que la mitad
cerca de 25.000 a ayuda operacional
ayuda burocrática para que el gobierno
de operando y 4.000 en ayuda humanitaria
concretamente en temas militares se han
dado más de 2.500 drones más de 1700 de
estas camionetas blindadas también
tanques de guerra superan
además de decenas de miles de armas de
cohetes y de municiones esto sin contar
los radares y también los cerca de 58
buques barcos costeros para la defensa
de las costas de Ucrania estas son
algunas de las cifras que se han
revelado por organismos que han sido
citados en medios nacionales acá en
Estados Unidos